bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo dio sono affari generis antaldi su
quickdrop idro di google che è una e di
gusto gioco cioè non so come spiegarlo
adesso ho capito dove vanno i soldi di
youtube da perché ve lo dico c'è nel
senso 45 per cento degli introiti di
youtube vanno a youtube poi vanno allo
youtube e quindi cosa ci fa google
comunque il 45 per cento perché youtube
di google è questo
ok per chi non lo sapesse questo gioco
ti da un elemento da disegnare tu lo
devi disegnare in 20 secondi
nel mentre google tenta di indovinare
quello che stai dicendo da te lo fa con
la voce meno irritante di sempre da una
nuvola allora disegna una pecora va bene
segna una pecora signori pure così scuro
non è un cespuglio
ma non è un altro aspetto è una pecora
bravo mancava la faccia però fragilità
da un'altra un'anguria ragazzi
un'anguria un'anguria penso non sia così
difficile
faccio un augurio la spezia
viviano certosino oppure opere di maria
capperi oppure una cosa la faccio
vedo una storia dei semini lustrava
perfetto uno scarabocchio è che se
facilissimi di uno zig zag ma pure una
stella è come d'oro fatto c'era bocchio
allora porto
vedo una stella non so come fai uno
scarabocchio perfetto una graffetta sono
stato bravissimo fino ad arrivare quasi
6 su 6 lo so che non è un'area di vetta
bellissimo un fagiolino mio dio
vedo un orecchio oppure una rapida da
une fagiolino si vede anni
con i fagioli fagioli vedo un gomito lo
so è un fasolino 6 su 6 ho fatto quasi
ragazzi e incredibile non riuscirò a per
tutto il video rifare 6 so se ve lo
giuro ore un pennarello
lo so è una padella ragazzi sei su sei
bellissimo lo riuscirò per tutto il
video a rifare senso sei molto difficile
quindi sono molto contento
vediamo subito che cosa ne pensano i
miei fan su twitter delle mie archi
vediamo subito che cosa ne pensano che
ha tratto fuori far vedere questo video
certo che sono con un ragazzo simpatico
per noemi sono contento grazie in questo
video comunque era solo a metà pensa
quanto diavola riso primo commento o
usciti here we go again
beh certo perché quando cerchi di fare
uno scarabeo skara biocco riesci un
fiore quando fai una pecora ti esce una
formula magica per evocare il satana
abbiamo scarabocchio fiore vero la
pecora formula magica per evocare satana
effettivamente ci sta come ha fatto
indovinare la piccola me lo chiedo
anch'io me lo chiedo anch'io non capisco
se la pecora la faccia o la coda
triangolare e la faccia quella però non
ho fatto in tempo a disegnarla però è la
faccia
ho capito che sono brutto ma farmi
almeno la faccia ho capito a ti chiami
eduardo pecora va bene va dai ragazzi
altra manche disegna un gatto in meno di
20 secondi amico mio non vedrai mai
capito una mazza da hockey
oppure una vera di una mazza da hockey
mano oppure una scarpa dato una vasca da
bagno 12 ragazzi ho sempre avuto
problemi a disegnarle sapere gli animali
oppure un pick up vedo un cane oppure un
orso che cane oppure uno scoiattolo
gatto si vede maledizione dai ho fatto
sei su sei non farò mai più niente
dappertutto il videogioco solo viene un
fiore vedo una pera
ma io voglio vedere annunciando htt
giusto video grazie una sirena madonna
viene anche nell'altro video ragazzine
impone un livello vedo un braccio
aspetta pure un dentifricio età lo so è
una sirena bene la cipolla piano ora ci
fa lembo di feeling da parte che non so
come sia fatta la cipollari non so è una
cipolla ma che bravo che sente un
violoncello benissimo il mio noncello è
tipo il violino molto più grosso vero
quindi siamo nella nota il cus ha così
oppure una clessidra
non vedo un fenicottero oppure un tappo
di bottiglia elicottero oppure un vaso è
scemo
lo so è un violoncello bravissimo sono
riuscita è questo il fenicottero quindi
mi basta fare qualcosa di prima di
crosta fare cose di prima
oppure un naso lo so è un fenicottero
com'è possibile come il fatto indovinare
il fenicottero c'è il gatto che era il
più bello di tutti questo è l'unico che
non indovina tubo il gatto di chernobyl
come darle torto questo cipolla e così
reale che guardando da viene quasi da
piangere
dai non era male in realtà come ha fatto
non prendere il gatto è visto che la
cosa fatta meglio non l'ha presa e la
cosa fatta meglio di tutte come ha fatto
e dove in aree fenicottero lo sa solo
lui è bello che con una essa abbia
indovinato fenicottero ma quando ci si è
impegnato per disegnare un gatto no
vabbè che il gatto sembrano a donne se
quello fenicottero tu avresti 100
milioni di iscritti ci hai ragione
quello che assomiglia di più la parola
da indovinare la proprio il gatto ma
vero io non so come abbia fatto made in
bo non ho capito giuro il gatto è
leggermente incazzato perché non li
hanno indovinato ok ragazzi questa
partenza di questa è veramente un casino
non so come fare una balena ve lo giuro
oppure una bocca lo so è una balena sto
facendo le cose però va bene perché non
guardo cosa scrive sotto prima lo scrive
poi lo dice potevo anche fermarmi ma
vabbè era un capolavoro comunque ragazzi
questo è un orecchio
vedo uno scarabocchio ma che scarabocchi
lo so è un originalissimo bangkok
un gelato madonna ragazzi ciccio proprio
l'arte che mi scorre nel sangue mosconi
un grattacielo
lo so è una vela primo sassofono cosa
non so non mi prenderete vi so cosa non
sassofono ma non so bene come è fatto
vedo lo zig zag pure un campo da golf lo
so bravissimo una faccina sorridente va
bene che st lisi vedo un uragano oppure
un paio di occhiali
lo so è una faccina sul mare gay una
mucca incredibile però ragazzi una luca
le mucche fanno mou però la mia è
veramente un casino da fare ve lo dico
allora gli animali sono sempre avuto
problemi e insegnati animali li faccio
tutti uguali unico non c'è niente che
nel che so fare morire maria strillo
oppure un rinoceronte quattro delle
quali se no lo so è una mucca brava
incredibile balena orecchio gelato sas
gelato bellissimo faccina sorridente e
mucca fantastico twitter a te la parola
ai ragazzi sono più che altro curioso di
vedere cosa ne pensate della musica
vediamo cosa rispondete
quando mi dicono di sorridere delle foto
[Musica]
sul quale la balena è un palloncino che
ci ha creduto tanto beh effettivamente
ma solo a me la balena ricorda una
coscia di pollo è veramente ricordo un
sacco di cose tranne che la balena non
mangerei michael gelato ma apprezzo
molto i ragazzi io sono fatto commenti
sulla mucca
ecco la mucca sembra un pokémon questo
il primo commento che quella non è una
mucca e la sua evoluzione
la balena se nel palloncino all'orecchio
fagiolo solo un paio di come la mucca
subito delle mutazioni la mucca sembra
il fantasmino di pacman vediamo è vero è
vero sembra il fantasmino di pac man o
dentifricio dentifricio dovrebbe essere
abbastanza il giorno e la base del
movimento lampada dei doors amico non
svetta gli facciamo gli facciamo il
movimento deve essere spremuto oppure un
pennarello
oppure una matita
che matita vedo un topo dai si capisce
adesso lo spazzolino dai era facile una
sega tua sorella da era facile questo la
lega porco demonio
la chevy fatta per farla bene uno
spazzolino oppure una cornice è una sega
anno a microonde è una sega cosa vuoi
che sia non farla micron
no ragazzi non ci credo vedo un diamante
[Musica]
oppure un facilissimo l'osserva sega una
pecora che sono fatta prima
vedo uno scarabocchio oppure una nuvola
lo so è una pecora bravissimo un
manubrio da palestra un malore della
palestra come lo faccio devo farlo un
pelo tondo vedo un ginocchio
oppure o nella soglia non ho giusto
formatore e una banana bravissimo vedo
oppure un orecchio ragazzi la rhino e
bellissimo pure un trampolino ragazzi è
fatto da tiro con tromboni e fatto
benissimo come è fatta non capirlo
stupida scorrendo che non manubrio la
palestra siberia benissimo linea nepi
per il culo
lo so è una linea e una ora quante ne
dovevo fare già un anno fa ho me lo
chiedi una le faccio una barca va un
altro che schifo che schifo
vedo veramente oggi e dominare non ci
stà impegnarli uno scarabocchio marche
scarabocchi aspetta pure un autobus ma
non è un autore una sim o camion dai
vedo un treno dai un camion bosco
demonio cosa sia
certo che se vere scuse ma guarda che
cosa non è indovina ha indovinato una
pecora una sega una linea che erano
quattro e poi noi giuriato manubrio che
l'ho fatta trovò facciamo pure il
culturista dietro il camion da è
facilissimo non è auto bus e camion
svegliate ragazzi questo era un episodio
di disegna cose in 20 secondi prima che
la cia tv sia la porta quindi spero che
vi sia piaciuto che va certamente un bel
mi piace io vi mando un bacino
se un disegnino a casa se lo volete se
non lo volete lo capisco chi vede nelle
schiacciate anche la campanellina e non
mi vorreste perdere mai notifiche di
video belli come questo è da ragazzi
[Musica]